ما هي الوجبات الرئيسية التي حصلت عليها من
درع المجتمع ،
فمن الجيد أن تفوز بها
[تصفيق]
كان هذا هو ثالث هدفنا ، لذا كان من الجيد
حقًا الفوز في هذا الوقت
بالعودة إلى الموسم التحضيري ونعلم في
أذهاننا أن موسمنا  يبدأ قبل أسبوع من حضور
أي شخص آخر ، وقد استعدنا
لذلك كان دافعنا
ألا نكون مستعدين لمباراة فولهام أوم في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
وعلينا أن نكون مستعدين للحفلات ، لأن
ذلك عندما يبدأ
موسمنا مباراة تنافسية ، هناك كأس
للاستيلاء عليها  دعنا نخرج ونفوز ، هل
تلعب أفضل فريق في البلد
حقًا ، لذا إذا
كنت ستفوز على أي شخص ، فتأكد من هزيمته ،
فمن المثير للاهتمام أن تذكر المدينة
لأنني أنظر إليها الآن أنظر إليها
اتساقهم هم الآن أكبر
منافس لك في الدوري الممتاز أم أنه
لا يزال متحدًا وإيفرتون
هناك طرق مختلفة تحتاج إلى النظر
إليها وأعتقد أنه تاريخيًا
، سيكون هناك دائمًا هذا التوتر
والمنافس  مع الأدلة ومتحدون ،
لكنني أعتقد
أنه في الوقت الحالي لأسباب
مختلفة سيكون هناك دائمًا كره
مع ليفربول ولن تكسب أبدًا ،
وستكون موحدتي دائمًا دائمًا وستكون دائمًا أنه
بغض النظر عن المكان الذي سينتهي فيه أي من الفريقين.
الدوري ، مهما كان ما يحدث ، فهم
دائمًا ما تعرف مباريات ساخنة للغاية
وكلا المشجعين يريد حقًا الفوز بها أكثر ،
لكني أعتقد أنه لأسباب مختلفة الآن ،
تعرف مان سيتي أنها أكبر مباراة في
الموسم وأفضل فريق فيها.  إنجلترا هي
واحدة من أفضل الفرق في العالم ، إن لم تكن
كذلك ، لذا فأنت تعلم بالنسبة لنا أنهم
الفريق الذي تعرف أنه
وضع السرعة في المعيار
لبقية الدوري الذي فعلوه حتى
تعرف أربع بطولات في خمس بطولات.  سنوات إنه
شيء
لا يمكن للعديد من الفرق أن تقول إنها
فعلته ، لذلك من الصعب علينا أن
ننظر إلى ما بعدهم ونبحث عن
أي مكان آخر حيث أن الدافع لدينا
هو إذا بقينا في المدينة وحولها
خلال السنوات الأربع أو الخمس الماضية  يو
أنت تعلم أنك في مكان جيد ، فمن
المثير للاهتمام أن تقول ذلك لأنه في اثنين من
المواسم الأربعة الماضية كنت
وراءهم بنقطة واحدة في مناسبة أخرى
بالطبع فزت بها
ورأيتهم ،
هل تتوقع اللقب  السباق ليكون
بينكما مرة أخرى ،
أتوقع أن يكون هذان الشخصان
في سباق اللقب ، أعتقد أن
الفرق الأخرى ستقترب ، وأعتقد أن
الفرق الأخرى ستغلق الفجوة ، أم
أنك تنظر إلى أمثال توتنهام
تشيلسي
حتى أن الترسانة الآن
توحدهم.  إعادة تقوية
الفرق والتعاقدات الجيدة مدربين من الطراز العالمي
في كل مكان في الدوري الآن أيضًا ، لذا
احفر الفجوة ، فأنا متأكد من أننا
سنقترب أكثر ومن يدري الشيء الوحيد الذي
يمكننا التفكير فيه هو المكان الذي نحتاج إلى
أن نكون فيه  وما نحتاج إلى القيام به وأعتقد
الآن أن هدفنا هو بوضوح أن نذهب إلى هناك
للفوز بالدوري ، وأعتقد أن هذا العام قد
يكون من أصعب المواجهات التي يجب أن نذهب
إليها ونفعلها لأن مستوى
المعارضة التي تلعبها أمامك  خرجت من
مستوى آخر مرة أخرى أعتقد أنك
تنظر إليه
أنت تعرف نهائيات دوري أبطال
أوروبا وأشياء من هذا
القبيل كانت الكثير من الفرق الإنجليزية
، وهكذا يظهر أن الدوري في مكان قوي
والفرق تعمل بشكل جيد
وأنت تعلم أن هذا ما تريد أن
تلعب فيه